comment vous allez bien j'espère alors
je suis très très sincèrement désolé je
suis extrêmement désolé aujourd'hui
parce que je vous parle de ce produit là
qui est très cool c'est un produit de
samsung s'est regardé ça écrit si noir
sur blanc ondées sur le scud c bon sens
le no cd samsung galaxy bewkes et le
samsung galaxy bewkes c'est un ultra
portable
on est dans cette nouvelle génération
d'ordinateurs 1 vous savez qu'ils sont
très légers très petit qu'on peut
emmener partout ouvrir partir se
connecter c'est très simple et c'est
très cool sauf que cet ultra portable de
samsung est bien n'est pas disponible en
france donc si vous êtes en france et
bien malheureusement vous ne pourrez pas
la voir par contre j'ai une bonne
nouvelle pour tous nos amis canadiens
bien vous pourrez trouver alors l'idée
aujourd'hui c'est patent de vous faire
un test complet de ce produit là parce
qu'on peut pas le trouver c'est plus de
vous parler de ce qu'il y a à
l'intérieur tout parlé d'une nouvelle
technologie techno qui se développe de
plus en plus et qui est extrêmement
intéressante aujourd'hui à parler de la
copie dean tél on va parler de ça line
tel lakefield pas si l'accent est très
très bon c'est dieu qui est pas trop
technique j'ai vraiment vous expliquer
qu'est ce qui se passe du côté de chez
intel avec ce produit là quelles sont
les nouvelles techno qu'ils soient en
place pour aussi d' une fois de plus de
se projeter dans l'avenir et de
comprendre comment fonctionnent ces
machines d'un nouveau genre parce que
oui là dessus on a une machine d'un
nouveau genre machine qui est bien qui
vous apportera de la flexibilité qui
permettra de travailler d'un peu partout
qui est vraiment axée sur la
productivité ce n'est pas du tout une
machine qui est fait pour les gamers
pour les personnes qui vont chercher
beaucoup de performances mais pour tous
ceux et toutes celles qui veulent un
ordinateur de bonne qualité qui va
pouvoir se connecter partout et pouvoir
travailler quel que soit l'endroit où
ils se trouvent
et bien c'est cette typologie de
produits qu'il vous faudra probablement
regardez-moi ça comme c'est mignon c'est
extrêmement léger tout l'intérêt de ce
cap là je voulus comme ça on a affaire
vraiment à un ultraportable que vous
venez ouvrir vous avez un capteur
d'empreintes digitales vous
déverrouillez lots monsieur grenet salut
ça c'est moi écran complètement tactile
et pour mieux naviguer faire tout ce que
vous voulez c'est pareil ça marche mais
ça c'est très cool
on est ici je le dis il faut de plus sur
un ultraportable une machine qui est
extrêmement fine qui est tout petit qui
est très légère comme j'ai un produit
qui peut distribuer dans les pays
anglo-saxons et bien je retrouve ici
avec un clavier qwerty mais ça je
voulais d'une fois de plus si vous êtes
en france
eh bien ce n'est pas un produit que vous
allez avoir le petit capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est là on a
un écran
ici deux
13 3 pouces full hd on a ici 8 gigas de
ram c'est le lay pédiatriques sont à 512
il ya de stockage extensible grâce à une
carte microsd jusqu'à 1 tera on a du
wifi 6 du bluetooth 5.0 une prise jack
de l'usbc d'un côté et de l'autre bien
pouvoir connecter ce que vous voulez
pouvoir recharger très facilement avril
on est sur une machine compacte une
machine qui est extrêmement légère qui
ne pèse pas plus de 950 grammes qui au
plus large fait 11 8 mm et pour
contrôler ce qu'à l'intérieur est bien
une telle afin petit partenariat avec
lego pour pouvoir voir comment
s'articulent ce processeur
le led field eh bien regardez j'ai fait
mon petit travail je vous ai monté et
les lego faut dire que j'adore les lego
pour essayer de comprendre un peu
comment s'articulent alors là vous vous
en douterez on n'est pas du tout à
taille réelle
vune c'est quelque chose qui est
beaucoup plus gros mais pour venir
illustrer le propos le light fils
ça ressemble à ça vous avez donc avoir
différentes parties qui vont être gérés
par votre processeur que soit la partie
au niveau de l'usbc joue pas ça très
rapidement pour qu'on essaye de
comprendre la partie et de stockage
différents capteurs tout ce qui va être
audio et au paf deuxième couche on a
réussi sur la gestion de la mémoire le
contrôleur sur la plénière 4x à je
voulais dit la gestion de l'énergie la
gestion graphique l'affichage avec votre
écran ici et vous avez deux parties pour
toute votre âme qui divise en quatre
parties ici en quatre parties la voyez
donc un peu comment s'articulent vote
les fils à l'intérieur d'ailleurs ça
vous intéresse c'est très rigolo
moi je me suis vraiment ma real contre
eux ça permet de voir un petit peu à
quoi ça ressemble même si effectivement
c'est tout petit ça fait appel la taille
d'un ongle tout ça on n'est vraiment pas
dans ce format là et si vous voulez vous
aussi fabriqué à regarder j'en ai deux à
vous offrir
je voulais un lien dans la description
il vous suffit de répondre à une petite
question il y aura ensuite un tirage au
sort pour gagner chacun le vôtre c'est
moi qui vous l'expédier est donc ça ça
va être rigolo si vous aimez les des
gaules vous voulez vous amuser vous êtes
vraiment des technophiles aidé à garder
il ya de quoi faire moi je veux pas
rentrer dans un discours trop trop trop
technique parce qu'au bout d'un moment
ça peut être un petit peu habitable pour
toutes les personnes que ça n'intéresse
pas nécessairement de comprendre est
réellement l'aspect trop technique mais
tous ceux et toutes celles qui veulent
comprendre ce qu'on peut faire avec ce
nouveau typologie de produits l'an
nouveau typologie de produits
oui certes fond des choses qui se
développe de plus en plus là on parle
d'une telle milhas pacte intel qui
proposent ce genre de solution mais
intel est quand même l'un des leaders
dans le domaine du portable d'un domaine
de l'ordinateur en règle
avec ces intel core et là encore on
parle que de cette partie là et avec
cette nouvelle architecture de
processeur ce que ça va venir nous
apporter c'est de la flexibilité pouvoir
travailler partout facilement sans se
prendre la tête avec une durée de vie de
batterie qui va être prolongé puisque
ont un ordinateur qui ne va pas
particulièrement consommés c'est un peu
tout d'intérêt alors une fois de plus ça
dépend des usages mais vous êtes quand
même parti pour quelques bonnes heures
de travail très facilement vous n'êtes
pas dans le process de vous dire
j'allume mon ordinateur je des mamans
windows je travaille à la fin je
l'éteins c'est pas ça l'idée que vous
allez à bord ici avec cette toute
nouvelle technologie de processeur et
d'ordinateur on peut dire comme ça avec
ces nouveaux ultraportables vous
l'ouvrez vous travaillez vous le clapet
vous partez vous trouverez vous
travaillez c'est de la flexibilité c'est
extrêmement simple alors ici ce n'est
pas un ordinateur qui est fait pour les
gamer c'est pas un ordinateur qui est
fait pour des personnes qui veulent
faire tourner des jeux un peu gourmand
des programmes trop gourmand va pas
faire du montage vidéo pourra
s'installer à photoshop mais avec
quelques calq et pas trop ce n'est pas
une technologie qui vous permettra
d'avoir des ordinateurs avec beaucoup de
performances
ce sont des ordinateurs qui seront
idéales pour je ne sais pas une flotte
de commercial qui veulent travailler
envoyer leur reporting sur leur crm pour
des étudiants qui sont à la fac qui
veulent pouvoir bosser facilement
rapidement avec une belle autonomie pour
une famille qui veut pouvoir tenir des
comptes tu veux pouvoir regarder
quelques films quelques séries pour des
personnes qui sont très souvent en
déplacement et qui ont besoin vraiment
de flexibilité ont les dents cet adn là
si vous êtes gamer vous voulez beaucoup
de performance qu'on voit une machine
qui carbure à font clairement là ce
n'est pas du tout fait pour vous alors
je sais pas d'ailleurs vous quels sont
vos usages avec vos ordinateurs et
ordinateurs portables d'ailleurs dites
le moi en bas en commentaire est ce que
cette typologie de produits pourrait
vous intéresser ce que c'est quelque
chose que vous avez déjà achetées chez
un concurrent
on peut parler de samsung mais c'est
vrai qu'en france ça me saoule sur les
portables c'est pas trop là-dessus qu'on
va bien les chercher
il ya d'autres marques propres et des
choses intéressantes et ce qui est bien
aussi avec intel est bien c'est qu'on
les retrouve un peu partout sur le
marché cette solution mais je trouve
très cool et surtout elle permet
d'entrevoir ou vision alternative de
l'ordinateur portable
jusqu'à il ya peu de temps l'ordinateur
portable on aller l'acheter en fonction
de ce qu'il y allait avoir sous le capot
mais on avait toujours
la même techno de base là on a une
techno qui est différente pas mal
d'entre apercevoir un autre avenir
d'autres usages et surtout une plus
grosse autonomie que ce qu'on pouvait
avoir avec un ordinateur un poil plus
classique
il ya toutes ces choses là qui sont
intéressantes et qu'on peut faire grâce
à une nouvelle architecture de
processeurs donc voyez ce qui est
intéressant c'est de voir comment une
technologie différente même si le
produit ressemble à un autre ordinateur
au delà du côté ultra portable est très
fin ça reste un ordinateur portable
comment une techno comme celle d' intel
avec son processeur avec son late fils
comment est ce qu'on arrive à
transformer l'ordinateur pour des usages
plus simple plus adapté quelqu'un qui
veut vraiment un ordi qu'on peut emmener
partout avec soi alors rassurez-vous
grâce à ce processeur vous êtes alors
rassurez vous avec ce processeur vous
êtes 100% compatible des applications 32
bits ou 64 bits x86 le processeur c'est
un intel core i5 l 16 g leygues field la
conception est vraiment radicalement
différent de ce qu'on peut retrouver
usuellement sur des processeurs intel
ici le fond notamment grâce à la
technologie fauves et ross 3ds que cette
technologie intel va permettre à des
constructeurs comme samsung ou encore
comme d'autres est bien c'est de
concevoir des ordinateurs plus fin plus
petit léger en n'ayant pas les
contraintes technologiques d'un
processeur un peu plus standard en
n'allant pas aussi loin en termes de
performances que ce qu'on pourrait
retrouver avec un intel core un peu plus
classique
le but de cette vidéo ce n'est pas
forcément de vous présenter cet
ordinateur de samsun même s'il est cool
parce qu'il n'est pas dispo en france
une fois de plus si vous êtes en france
d'ailleurs dit moi vous en commentaires
ou est-ce que vous vous situez dans le
globe dans quel pays est ce que vous
êtes les plus tôt les six d'entre eux
voir comment ce processeur intel core
lake field nous permet d'entrapercevoir
une nouvelle catégorie de produit une
nouvelle catégorie d'ordinateurs de
comprendre un peu les usages derrière et
si vous voulez aller plus loin en termes
de compréhension technologique est
vraiment rentré dans le fond du problème
et tout côté technologique qui si vous
êtes vraiment intéressé par aimant le
côté 100% techno et bien je vous mets un
lien en bas dans la description pour en
savoir plus sur cette nouvelle
technologie intel
moi en tout cas je trouve ça bien ça
vous permet d'allumer votre ordinateur
plus rapidement ça me permet d'arriver
directement sur l' usage vous le prenez
vous l'ouvrez tac vous déverrouillez
avec votre doigt vous
directement connecté à votre ordinateur
c'est très simple très pratique
perso j'aime bien dites-moi si cette
nouvelle catégorie de produits et biens
pourrait vous tentez est-ce que ça
correspondrait à vos usages ou alors est
ce qu a contrario vous avez besoin de
beaucoup de performances et même s'il ya
des avantages en termes d'autonomie de
rapidité de connectivité et bien ce
n'est pas nécessairement fait pour vous
dites moi tout ça en bas en commentaire
quant à nous on retrouve extrêmement
rapidement pour parler de teck parce que
oui il ya plein de choses qui arrivent
même si en ce moment j'ai un peu moins
de temps pour faire des vidéos sur ma
chaîne youtube puisque je tourne une
série de onze émissions pour amazon
d'ombré c'est un peu la course est très
très speed mais à partir de fin octobre
début novembre
on sera plus cool ou repartir à fond un
regard dans tous les produits notamment
pour les produits pour cette fin d'année
dont croyez moi restez connectés abonnez
vous il ya plein mais plein de belles
choses qui arrivent sur ce j'envoie ont
beaucoup d'amour
prenez soin de vous et à très vite ciao
[Musique]
ce feu
m
[Musique]